Which pieces read 361 + 544?
Let's face it, each of them begins with 361,
then we add 544 on it.
In this description, plus 400 plus 50 plus 4,
which means 544 instead of 454,
In this example, plus 500 plus 40 plus 4,
which is 544 plus 361,
resulting in 905.
This is logical, we add 500, we get 861.
then 40 plus is equal to 901, 4 more
so we get 905 that we choose this answer.
and another example shows 50 instead of 500,
this is not true.
because we are 5 hundred, 4 or 40, later
Adding 4 solitude, let's look at other examples.
The following numbers are for axes
Which phrase is appropriate?
Let's see, 718 plus 200
then the plus 40 is equal to 958
This, in fact, means 718 + 240.
so we choose this answer.
It looks kind of fun.
The reading of the numbers explains the calculation of 585 - 368.
Let's see these two pieces of arrows
Both begin with 585, and our calculation is related to this number.
It starts with 558, where the figures have changed.
This is not true.
But we are looking at these two options.
We want to go out to 3, 6, and 8 alone.
In both of these, we go up to three hundred,
then we want to go out to six.
When we get six decimal places and eight alone, we get this answer.
In this example instead of 6 decimal and 8 loneliness
8 decimal places and 6 singles,
Since there are 386 deductible here
We choose the third answer.
Here's another example.
The following numbers are for axes
what the answer is correct.
Started at 935, then 400,
then we turn 20.
This means 935 - 420.
935 - 420.
This answer is correct.